I was growing up from the ages of 9 to
14 I only read stephen king books
outside of school I remember when I was
in third grade her fourth grade I we all
had to write down what are the books we
read over the summer and I remember the
expression on Miss syllables face my
teacher when I wrote the dead zone and
the Tommyknockers she is really
horrified and upset and that that's when
I think I knew I was doing the right
right thing so Stephen King was always
actually big influence on growing up I
went through a phase late later in my
adolescence when I was reading a lot of
the British writers of Martin Amis
generation early Ian McEwan Julian
Barnes especially those 3 i'd suppose
read a lot of dickens and i really love
dickens and then in college I studied
literature and I I studied 20th century
European literature so that those are
the things I've read the most and ever
since I started working at the parish
review I've been reading a lot of
contemporary American fiction to try to
catch up a little bit
you